today on the matt walsh show an unarmed
woman was shot and killed by police when
the capitol was taken over on wednesday
all the people who have spent years
shouting about the killing of unarmed
civilians have been mysteriously silent
about this case or if not silence they
have celebrated the woman's death
outright also five headlines including
the democrats hatching a plan to remove
trump from office even though he's gonna
be gone anyway from office in two weeks
uh and we'll cancel a former nba star
who says that the riot in dc was an
example of white supremacy somehow and
his argument gets even more absurd from
there we'll talk about all that and more
today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know i think what you're looking for
in clothing at least what i'm looking
for is you want them to be comfortable
but it also has to look like you care
about how you look because you know
anyone could just
throw on some sweatpants
a stained you know sweatshirt or
something
slippers
go to walmart anyone could do that um
and uh and uh sometimes we're tempted
maybe as as men to do that but you have
to also care about how you look and
that's where mack weldon comes in there
are lots of things that you'd probably
like to leave behind in 2020 one of the
most important being your old under
underwear drawer if you're rolling into
the new year with the same bunching
chafing and uncomfortable underwear that
you've got to check out mac welded mac
weld is essential piece of my daily
routine they've got pretty much
everything you need as far as as far as
clothing they've got men's essentials
socks shirts hoodies underwear polos
active shorts
and there's also a lot of versatility to
their clothing because you look great
and you feel great if you're working out
going out going to work on a going to
work going to going on a date
probably not doing all those things at
the same time but mack weldon is for
everyday life and there's there's real
technology in their clothing as well
because they've got a wide range of
customized fabrics that can
keep up with you no matter what your day
looks like and on top of that they've
got weld and blue which i would
recommend it's totally free it's a
loyalty program level one gets you free
shipping for life once you reach level
two by spending 200 bucks to get 20 off
every order for the next year uh i love
what mac weldon personally i'm wearing
mac welding right now this shirt is a is
a mack weldon
masterpiece and um it of course is plaid
i don't know if it comes through in the
in the camera
but when when i was when i was asked you
know when mac weldon came aboard
and my first question to them was do you
have plaid
and they said we do and i said i'm sold
so for 20 off your first order visit
mackweldon.com walsh and enter promo
code walsh that's macweldon.com walsh
promo code walls for 20 off mack weldon
reinventing men's basics now if we're
able to think back and conjure up
ancient history we may recall the night
of may 28th
of this past year 2020 when rioters were
demolishing the city of minneapolis in
response to the death of george floyd
in the middle of that night of chaos
rioters forced their way into the
minneapolis third precinct police
officers then abandoned the building
driving hastily away in vehicles or
retreating on foot in in full riot gear
as the mob hurled rocks and fireworks at
them reportedly city council members had
been begging the police chief and the
mayor to surrender the building to the
riders for fear that defending it would
only further enrage them we'd want to
make them angry by defending the police
station so the building was surrendered
and eventually it was ransacked and
torched
now this one incident one of many
similar incidents in minneapolis and
other major cities across the country
over the summer single-handedly puts to
rest any claim that police used
more violent tactics against blm riders
than they did against the riders at
capitol hill this week
it is very hard to make such a case when
police quite literally handed their
precinct over to the writers and sat
back and watched them burn it to the
ground
let's imagine something
what if cops had decided to stand and
fight
defending their building from the
rampaging mob
and what if they had used lethal force
to do so
and what if in the ensuing melee an
unarmed black woman
had been shot at near point-blank range
in the neck and killed as she tried to
climb through a broken window into the
police station what if that had happened
can there be any doubt about the public
and political reaction to such an event
is there any chance
that the blm antifa set in the media and
the democratic party would ignore the
woman's death or outright defend the
officer on the basis that the black
woman didn't belong there shouldn't have
been climbing in the window and so
deserve to be killed is such a reaction
conceivable
i think we all know it's not
this hypothetical woman
let's pretend her name was say i don't
know ashley babbitt
she would be memorialized with building
size murals and more rioting would be
conducted on her behalf and athletes
like lebron james would put her name on
his jersey and exhort us to say her name
the outrage over her death would be
nuclear in proportion and her name would
be famous in death a martyr for the
cause another canonized saint for social
justice
that is how it would have gone with the
hypothetical ashley babbitt and we all
know it
what about the real ashley babbitt
though
the real ashley babbitt a white trump
supporter
was killed in real life
while participating in the swarm on the
capitol building on wednesday
according to reports she was unarmed
didn't have a weapon
video of the incident shows that she was
attempting to climb through a broken
window when an officer shoots her in the
neck and kills her this is inside the
capitol building
now we've heard quite a lot about the
killing of unarmed civilians and the
harsh treatment of rioters and here we
have an example of both
she was unarmed she was killed and i
would say shooting someone that's pretty
harsh treatment
but this ashley babbitt has not gotten
the sort of treatment and attention that
our hypothetical ashley babbitt would
have received nor has she gotten their
treatment or attention that
non-hypothetical violent un violent
armed felons
not unarmed but armed felons like jacob
blake have received
after getting shot by police
in this case ashley babbitt
has been mostly ignored by the media and
the left
most of the scant attention her death
has attracted has been in the form of
what the left would normally call victim
blaming
perusing google this morning i could not
find a single headline
a single one in any major publication
that identified her as an unarmed woman
in the headline
which is strange because usually unarmed
is the first thing they tell us in these
kinds of situations
the next thing they tell us is the race
of the person
usually
most of the headlines that i've seen
about this shooting are like this one
from nbc news that says woman killed in
capital was trump supporter who embraced
conspiracy theories
now the article goes on
into great detail um
telling us about all the sins the dead
woman committed on social media for
example
quoting from the article says using the
handle common ash sense
babbitt's twitter account was almost
singularly focused on radical
conservative topics and conspiracy
theories
among other fringe beliefs she tweeted
about pizzagate a viral disinformation
campaign that falsely alleged a child
abuse ring was being operated by
democrats from a washington pizza
restaurant
babbitt was a loyal fox news watcher
according to thousands of tweets to fox
news host but she also engaged on social
media with the conspiracy news internet
news site uh infowars
in 2020 babbitt began to tweet with q
anon accounts and use q anon hashtags q
anon conspiracy theories subscribe to a
false belief that high profile democrats
and hollywood celebrities are ritually
sacrificing children that trump is
fighting to stop it two announced
followers have allegedly committed
real-world violent crimes including
murder and the fbi labeled it
a potential domestic terror threat in
2019 unquote
so those now you know again normally
somebody's killed by police we're told
that
um details about their life are
irrelevant
the fact that george floyd
forced his way into a woman's house and
put a gun to her stomach
that's not relevant we can't talk about
that
but the fact that ashley babbitt tweeted
some kooky conspiracy theories
that's relevant
many more details are provided about
babbitt's tweeting habits
as for information on the shooting
itself
almost nothing is provided at all
in fact i could find only one mention of
the fact that she was unarmed in any
mainstream publication forget about just
the headline okay it's not in any
headline but is it even in the article
i found one article one
the washington post in the last sentence
of the third paragraph of its article on
the shooting quotes two law enforcement
officials who confirm that she was
unarmed
now could the shooting still be
justified babbitt was
where she should not have been doing
something that she should not have been
doing that's clear
but if that alone justifies deadly force
then police would have license to kill
many people at many of the riots that
have broken out around the country
it's hard to see how the officer who
pulled the trigger could have reasonably
viewed babbitt
as a lethal threat to himself or anyone
else she's a small unarmed woman
climbing through a window
could they not have pushed her back
could they not have taken her to the
ground and cuffed her
video shows and this is really important
there was a whole line of armed heavily
armed law enforcement officers coming up
the steps directly behind her
i mean they were a few feet from her
when she was killed could none of them
have simply grabbed her and pulled her
away
or are the reports wrong did ashley
babbitt actually have a weapon or did
the officer think she had one i doubt it
based on the video footage but i don't
know because the media isn't bothering
to ask
did he fire because she was wearing a
backpack and he thought there might be
explosives in it
again that seems dubious since lots of
people were wearing backpacks and they
didn't kill anybody else
and lots of people at other riots wear
bags and that's never a justification to
shoot any of them
again it's hard again it's hard to know
because the media isn't bothering to
look for answers
nobody is demanding accountability
do we even know the name of the officer
who pulled the trigger
has he been put on administrative leave
while the investigation is underway as
as is usually par for the course in
these situations
there appears to be little interest in
these questions the people who have
again spent years panicking over police
shootings especially police shootings of
unarmed people are happy to simply
let this one slide
just let it go
we won't even ask about it
this is not what would happen
if ashley babbitt had a different
political affiliation and a different
skin color
and that is not a double standard that
we should simply accept
and say well that's just the way it goes
the media only cares and reports
if um you know you're on the left and
especially if you're not white
i don't think we should just accept that
one thing is clear the left has poured
into the streets to protest and riot
over police shootings that were easily
more justified than this
starting with michael brown
who was who was uh killed while in the
process of assaulting a police officer
and trying to take his gun
there's no rational argument that would
make brown's killing wrong
but babbitt's killing right
the double standard and the apparent
incoherence here is only confusing until
you realize
that the movement against police
brutality actually has nothing at all to
do with police brutality and never did
the deaths of men like brown were simply
excuses
they provided cover a forum they were a
trojan horse
tragedies used to justify anarchy and to
enact the left's radical cultural agenda
if the concern was really over brutality
then these people would at least be
asking questions about ashley babbitt's
killing
they would at least be demanding some
answers
they would at least care
but they don't
because they're frauds
and always have been
let's get now to our five headlines
[Music]
well the good news is that the brands
the brands are on the case the brands
are speaking out um that's that that's
the good news chevron coca-cola bank of
america they've all come out and
denounced the dc riot and ben and
jerry's uh thank god also you know you
need your ice cream to be to you need
your ice cream to stay woke your ice
cream needs to stay frozen and stay woke
that's what i always say that's i say it
all the time
personally i like for my ice cream um i
you know here's how i usually like my
ice cream serve with with whipped cream
hot fudge and a sprinkling of social
consciousness just a sprinkling
rainbow sprinkles actually are the the
socially conscious ones but then also
axe body spray okay they have also come
out and spoken out about this
um which i would have expected this of
like calvin klein cologne something
slightly more elitist but axe body spray
is the working man's scent
well it's xbody spray is the working man
scent
before he's a working man when he's
still in high school and attending his
first
homecoming dance
but either way um here's what axe body
spray said somebody pointed out that a
bottle of axe body spray was was left
behind in the capital after the riot and
um
the company uh came out
and
uh and said here's their quote he said
we'd rather be lonely than with the mob
acts condemns yesterday's acts of
violence and hate at the capitol we
believe in the democratic process and
the peaceful transition of power
so that's that's great
you want your body sprayed to believe in
the democratic process
at least maybe you do i don't personally
i i prefer a more i prefer more
authoritarian body sprays um
i like to douse myself in the scent of
despotism in the morning
i think i'm i'm smelling especially
tyrannical uh today in fact so that's
that's how i am but if you if you like
the socially conscious body sprays then
go pick up acts all right that wasn't
even a headline i would just mention
that let's go to number one here the
democrats uh democrats led by nancy
pelosi
are now all in on a plan to remove trump
from office and they're calling on mike
pence to do the deed
this again even though
donald trump one way or another i mean
even if you were still holding on hope
holding on to some hope that uh somehow
donald trump would still be president on
january 21st
that that now has to be completely gone
he's not going to be president um
and so what's the point of removing him
from office
well first we'll listen to nancy pelosi
this is what nancy pelosi had to say in
calling for this seditious act
president has committed an unspeakable
assault
on our nation
and our people
i joined the senate democratic leader in
calling on the vice president to remove
this president
by immediately invoking the 25th
amendment
if the vice president and cabinet do not
act
the congress may be prepared to move
forward with impeachment
that is the overwhelming sentiment
of my caucus
to those whose purpose was to deter our
responsibility
you have failed
you did not divert the congress from our
solemn constitutional purpose
to validate the overwhelming election
of joe biden and kamel harris as
president and vice president of the
united states we're very pleased now
that we have in 13 days
president
joe biden a democratic house majority
and a democratic senate majority that
will
work to heal
to heal and restore the soul of our
nation
yeah
putting aside any of the individual
claims she makes there let just just
talking about this idea of uh we're
going to remove trump from office
when there's two weeks left
there's only one reason and i don't
think they're actually going to succeed
at doing this
um
they might impeach them but
it's actually removing from office i
don't think it's gonna happen and the
idea of invoking the 25th amendment and
pence yeah i i i
it wouldn't surprise me to learn i mean
the reports are that pence is furious at
donald trump because trump just threw
him under the bus and tossed them to the
wolves and i don't blame pence for being
furious for that i would be too
but i sincerely doubt that pence would
go along with this
so i don't think it's actually going to
happen but
there's only one reason
to try to do this there's only one
reason to try to remove donald trump
from office
when he's only got two weeks left anyway
and that is if you want chaos and
violence if you want more chaos and
violence i should say
if you want to make everything worse
and if you want to milk
every every last day of trump's
presidency for all the chaos it's worth
then you would do this because that's
what's going to happen
you just saw how some people reacted
you know to the certification of the
votes can you can you imagine what
happens
if you remove him from office
utter chaos
um but that's what the democrats want
politically because it's very
politically advantageous for them so
that's the only reason they're talking
about this because that's what they want
i mean even if you were to
just uh for the sake of argument just
grant
that donald trump is this dangerous
monster and so so yadda yadda and so
forth
even then he's out of office
in a few days
so that's what the democrats are going
to try to do and that's what we have to
prepare for
they're going to milk this for all it's
worth
they've got you know they've got two
weeks left of donald trump and they're
going to try to get everything they can
out of that politically
which means chaos and anarchy and
division and all of that
all right um speaking of which number
two joe biden gave a speech yesterday
there are um
there are you know many different
directions he could have gone with this
speech one direction the right direction
would be to speak to all americans and
to call for an end to the unrest i don't
think it would really amount to much but
that's what he should have said
instead he decided to throw more
grenades into the crowd metaphorically
he decided to engage in some patented
democratic race hustling and let's uh
listen to that here
what we saw yesterday
in plain view was another violation of
the fundamental tenet of this nation
not only do we see the failure to
protect one of the three branches of our
government
we also saw a clear failure to carry out
equal justice
i don't know she used to say in the
senate excuse a point of personal
privilege
a little over an hour and a half after
the chaos started i got a
text
from my granddaughter finnegan biden
who's a senior in her last semester
at the university of pennsylvania
she sent me a photo
of military people
in full
military gear
scores of them lining the steps of the
lincoln memorial
because of protests by black lives
matter
she said pop
this isn't fair
no one can tell me
that it had been a group of black lives
matter protesting yesterday
there wouldn't have been they wouldn't
have been treated very very differently
than the mob of thugs that stormed the
capital
well we all know that's true
and it is unacceptable
totally unacceptable
yeah you're right they would have been
treated differently
i mean the capitol police probably would
have just vacated the premises entirely
handed it over to them like they did
with the police stations like they did
with many buildings around the country
entire buildings
hand it over to the blm writers to just
do what you want with it
so yeah they would have been treated
differently joe
i think we also have we'll play this too
just just to just to uh show how this is
a full-court press by the democrats to
stir up
as much division as they can in the
middle of this yeah here's wait i think
we have camilla harris she's pushing the
exact same lie uh here she is
we witnessed two systems of justice
when we saw one that let extremists
storm the united states capital
and another
that released tear gas on peaceful
protesters last summer
the american people have expressed
brightly
outrage
we know
this is unacceptable
we know
we should be
better than this
and of course uh
nothing even approaching this
came from camille harris or joe biden
during the riots in the summer
uh well we're better than this this is
none of that
joe biden called the people at the
capitol
thugs what he said a mob of thugs
you think he used that phrase to talk
about the blm writers you think he did
i'd go back and check but i'm just going
to say right now he didn't
i've already addressed this live many
times and i'll but i'll continue to
address it um this is just simply false
and it's it is it is
we we are being asked to cooperate with
the democrats as they
rewrite history
not ancient history
but history that just happened and we
all lived through and we all saw and
many of us saw in our own communities
it's just complete and total nonsense
number three is from the daily wires
officials in los angeles county are
warning that areas more
warning the areas more than 10 million
residents that
simply stepping outside is now deemed
risky behavior within the nation's
pandemic epicenter
los angeles county public health
director barbara ferrer said everyone
should keep in mind that community
transition rates are so high that you
run the risk of an exposure whenever you
leave your home
assume that this deadly invisible virus
is everywhere
looking for a willing host
well that's a that's a healthy way to
live isn't it
assume it's everywhere
searching for you
that's you know
that and that is how many people have
lived and that's why we've seen the
collapse of mental health in this
country
that's one of the reasons we've seen
suicide rates go up
because of this not only the
people aren't just being isolated but
they're having this fear and paranoia
hammered into their minds and their
their heads every second of the day
but you know it
from from one perspective she's right
that um
stepping outside your house is risky
behavior in a sense
every time you leave your home it's a
risk
because anything could happen you could
get hit by a bus crossing the street the
thing is that's the case whether there's
a pandemic or not
it is risky babe to do anything is risky
behavior to leave your home as a risky
baby to go into a crowded you know to go
to a crowded area is risky behavior even
if there's no coronavirus there are
other diseases
there you know who knows what could
happen a shooter could come i mean
anything could happen
of course when you think about that even
being in your house is risky people die
in their homes all the time fought on
the steps
there are many risks that we face as
human beings
but that's not a reason to stop living
our lives
we we are supposed to live our lives in
spite of the risk what we cannot do is
stop living until the risks go away
because they'll never go away
number four from nbc news says the
acting u.s attorney in washington mike
sherwin says his office has now charged
55 suspects with various offenses
including unlawful entry assault theft
and weapons charges
this in relation to what happened on
wednesday
eight suspects
faced gun charges one suspect had a
military-style semi-automatic rifle and
11 molotov cocktails sherwin says
federal local investigators hundreds of
people are now searching social media
for photos and video clips of suspects
engaged in unlawful activity
those people are being arrested as
quickly as possible department of
justice expects this search to for
suspects to last all year
now
i
this is good i i think yeah i have had a
consistent stance on this all along this
has always been my i actually believe in
law and order i'm a law and order guy i
always have been
so
when you've got
mobs of people committing crimes
arrest them absolutely
and if they're dumb enough to do it on
camera
without even having their faces covered
find them and arrest them
100 percent that's my stance
but i can't help but notice that
you know
when
our lawmakers in dc
because they're on top of this right
they're they're the ones they're
organizing task forces and they're
they're you know they're they're
mobilizing and they're saying let's find
these people and arrest them
so our lawmakers in dc
when their place of work is attacked and
the windows are broken
that's when they want to mobilize
but
when
you know someone else's workplace is
vandalized
invaded looted ransacked burned they
don't care about that
many americans what what the
what our lawmakers experienced on
wednesday
many americans
hundreds thousands
over the course of the last several
months have experienced exactly that and
worse
much worse in some cases
they've experienced their their uh
places of of
employment being burned to the ground
which i would say is is worse
for you if you work there than than
having the windows broken right so many
americans have experienced at least that
sometimes much worse
but didn't seem like anyone dc cared
about that there's really there's very
little mobilization happening
the doj is not doing much about it
they claim they're gonna do something
about they're not
in fact uh we they they
charges are dropped against the rioters
in those cases
there's a very good chance if you go and
you know you go burn down your local
convenience store
of course the person who works there he
might be hurt or killed in the process
who cares about that apparently
he's going to lose his whole livelihood
they're not setting up any task force
for that
uh i i find that to be obscene i just do
and i also find this logic to be obscene
i i find it to i i cannot agree
that um
you know it is it is better to
burn down
and attack your neighbor's place of work
than it is to attack
you know
our politicians place of work
i don't agree with that i think they're
both bad
but what we're being told by the media
the left and democrats
is that this it is so much worse to
attack where our politicians work
so much worse than simply victimizing
your neighbor at his place of work
again i find that logic to be obscene
and i absolutely reject it
all of this energy
all of this energy and effort should
have also been expended to deal with the
rioters
who are victimizing their own
communities
innocent civilians
all right number five from the new york
post it says
a prominent human rights attorney
apparently apparently posed as a latina
woman for years despite claiming puerto
rican and colombian heritage for over a
decade natasha lycia
i'm sorry her name is natasha lucia ora
bannon
is actually a white woman from georgia
according to a report by the non-profit
news outlet prism
she serves senior counsel at the latino
justice puerto rican legal defense and
education fund
records obtained by the site say uh
bannon's family arrived in the united
states from ireland italy and russia on
on monday bannon 43 clarified that she's
white in response to the report she says
i'm racially white and always have
always said that however my cultural
identity was formed as a result of my
family both chosen and chosen for me and
that has always been la tinx
so you know right away see i i didn't
even need to read any of the rest of
this
i already knew that she wasn't really
latina because she called herself latinx
that that's a white thing for sure that
is a a woke liberal
white thing
latinx or latinx
uh she says my identity is my most
authentic expression of who i am and how
i pay honor to the people who have
formed me since i was a child
so we have uh we have yet another it's
just just another example
someone posing white person posing as
non-white and of course all all the same
points that i've raised before can be
raised here uh and should be raised
about how
you know if we really live in a society
of white privilege
where non-white people are oppressed and
you you are afforded all of this
mysterious privilege just for being
white why do we have so many white
people forfeiting that privilege
and posing as an oppressed person so
that they can also be oppressed
that doesn't make a lot of sense does it
and the other
common point here but an important point
is
that by
by leftist logic
and the way we look at identity these
days as this entirely fluid thing this
this self-determined thing where you get
to decide your own identity you can even
decide you know not just your hair color
but you could decide
your biological identity you could
change your your sex if you want to
so if that's the case then
why can't she be latinx
why not i mean she could be whatever
ethnicity or race she wants it would
seem
the logic she's using here the defense
she offers for herself my identity is my
most authentic expression uh you know
this is how i
feel it doesn't really make any sense
but
by the left's way of thinking
it does
in fact it is it is far less absurd
and far more plausible for a white
person to claim to be
you know latino or black that is far
less absurd and far more plausible than
a man claiming to be a woman
lots of parents have been thinking about
and exploring homeschooling there's been
a huge surge in homeschooling which i
which i think is is a good thing you
know it's it's one
one small bright spot to come out of
everything that's happened over the last
year is that at least parents are
starting to think about homeschooling
which is a great option no matter what's
happening in the world
but to the parents who are concerned
about the coming school school semester
for their school-aged children
there's a new option for homeschooling
if you're thinking about homeschooling
you don't know how you're going to go
about it seems kind of overwhelming well
let me tell you about homeschool magnet
with school schedules always changing in
the challenges of so-called zoom school
now is the perfect time to consider
homeschooling homeschool magnet supports
homeschooling families by providing
students with instruction from
world-class credentialed teachers in a
remote classroom with their peers each
student receives quality instruction in
the four core subject areas of math
english science and social studies uh
parents ultimately have the freedom to
involve their students in as much or as
little learning
as they prefer based on their students
uh on on you know their child's goals so
that that's a big part of homeschooling
as a home school family ourselves um
this is what we love about homeschooling
is that it gives us the power
uh it's not a cookie cutter situation
you're not handing your kids over to the
government and letting them decide it uh
homeschool magnet is all about that as
well homeschool magnet is only a
fraction of the cost of private schools
and the money-back guarantee upon
enrollment means this choice is
risk-free with discounted prepay or
simple monthly payments homeschool mag
has an option to fit your needs so save
10 for every child when you use promo
code walsh uh when you enroll to learn
more about homeschool magnet and enroll
in the spring 2021 semester go to
homeschoolmagnet.com today and use walsh
when you enroll also
you know there's a reason why the media
creates narratives about conservatives
and uh it gets away with those
narratives in fact those narratives are
adopted into the culture people start
believing those narratives and the
reason is that they shape the content we
consume they control the entertainment
uh for a long time conservatives have
ceded creative ground to the left and
it's resulted in a culture that dictates
political correctness over freedom of
thought and dictates a lot more besides
that so we're pushing back against
cultural blacklisting on friday january
15th daily wire is releasing its first
feature film run hide fight
is exclusively going to be released two
daily wire members run hide fight isn't
a political film but it is intense it's
got a powerful message the movie follows
a high school siege by a quartet of
school shooters when one young girl 17
year old zoe hall uses her wits and
survival skills to fight back here's the
trailer
[Music]
in between breath
take a shot
you're doing really good out there kid
size of that deer we're going to be
eating venison all summer well the day's
work
i think we need to see somebody again
and by what you mean me no i mean us hey
that look in your eye guys in my unit
had that look maybe there's a brochure
you can have me so i can go
[Music]
is that chris angelic over there is he
doing something completely weird senior
prank day but we'll see all kinds of
dumb stuff today swim captain we'll have
typhoo delivered to class and becky
vaughan will set up her homemade slip
and slide this is high school
nothing that happens here matters in the
real world
[Music]
okay we
are in charge now so please pull out
whichever app you use to do live
streaming video get them up and running
and point it at me
now down on the ground any more friends
back there
i'm calling 911
you must be close
[Music]
you should be ashamed
very disturbing news out of vernon
central high school
[Music]
zoe
in between breath
take a shot
go
is it safe to say that this might be our
guardian angel do you want more people
to die that's the last thing i want i'm
gonna kill one person in this room every
five minutes you don't show your face
isn't it ironic that after all your hard
work
people aren't gonna remember you
no
you're gonna remember me
so to mark the release we'll be doing a
live stream premiere the night before on
thursday january 14th during a special
episode of backstage featuring jeremy
boring ben shapiro and special guest
come join us as we put the culture
back on our own terms
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we're going to cancel ethan thomas
who's a former nba player now identifies
as a quote poet activist and
motivational speaker
which is also what i have on my own
resume incidentally that's how i
describe myself thomas is being canceled
for this article published in the
guardian with this headline
nba players weren't surprised by dc we
live with white supremacy every day
now to be fair to ethan thomas he's not
the only one claiming that the invasion
of the capitol building was somehow a
racist act that's become a common
talking point on the left because of
course everything is racist to them they
would say it was racist when those same
people got up in the morning and ate a
muffin at the continental breakfast in
their hotel it was a racist breakfast
when they took a shower it was a racist
shower
and they put on their shoes they're
putting on racist shoes
everything's racist everything they do
is racist so of course this was racist
too
but there's also a lot of other great
stuff in this article so let's go
through it
it says quote
the silence has been deafening on the
right from from the right-wing
evangelicals who had prayed for donald
trump to be reelected to the all lives
matter and blue lives matter crowds to
the kaepernick haters and those who
denigrated black lives matter as violent
thugs in the wake of a mob of trump
supporters invading the u.s capitol an
attempt in an attempted coup on
wednesday
the same people who rushed to condemn
peaceful protests against racism are
either silent or ludicrously blame the
scenes on antifa
now let's pause here for a moment this
is completely false all the way through
on every level
everything about this is false this is
what we're up against it's why it can be
hard to argue with the left because the
lies pile up so quickly and so
numerously that you don't even know
where to begin this is just the first
paragraph already he's lied by saying
the blm riots were peaceful protests
they weren't a good rule of thumb here
is that a protest is not peaceful
if buildings are in ashes at the
conclusion of it and if people are dead
on the ground that's really good
evidence like when you walk into a scene
after the so-called protest has
concluded and you look around and you
see broken bottles and bricks thrown all
over the place and
smoldering buildings and dead people
pretty good evidence that what just
happened was not a peaceful protest
and um also it's not true that
the right has been silent about what
happened in dc in fact everybody on the
right has denounced the capital siege
every republican every single one
i cannot think of one republican who has
not denounced it
on the other hand i can't think of one
democrat who has denounced the blm riots
make of that what you will
let's continue skipping ahead a little
bit it says and yet the reaction of
large parts of middle america was shock
that white supremacists could invade the
heart of u.s democracy largely
undisturbed strolling through the
capital like it was their own private
kingdom
again the lies are oozing thickly from
every word
first white supremacists
where's the evidence of that
also undisturbed
they killed one of them
one of the undisturbed rioters is dead
and the entire federal government is on
the case and determined to arrest and
prosecute all the rest of them
so this is all untrue continuing
but none of this came as a surprise to
nba players 80 of whom are black
and see the effects of white supremacy
every day
okay i gotta take another pause here you
know as the kids say i i can't even
i just can't i can't even with this
now he is presenting nba players as an
especially aggrieved group
that lives with the effect of white
supremacy every day
what are those effects
the average salary of an nba player
average
is eight million dollars almost 7.7
million okay
a few shy of 8 million
that that's just the average many are
making hundreds of millions
is this the effect of white supremacy
that you're talking about
if so
i wish i could get some of those effects
if this is the oppression then sign me
up for it
but maybe thomas will make a reasonable
case maybe he'll explain how exactly nba
players are victims not just victims but
special victims they're especially of
all people you know the ones who have
seen white supremacy perhaps thomas will
prove his point what we'll find out
going back to the article he quotes from
other nba players and coaches and then
finally it says
anyone who's still having trouble
recognizing white privilege after we saw
after what we saw this week is simply a
denial
black american nba players know this
they have witnessed it their entire
lives
they're using their fame to get the
message into homes across america and
the world hoping something will change
that's why milwaukee bucks and detroit
pistons players knelt at the start of
their game on wednesday night it's why
colin kaepernick knelt in the first
place
and that's it
he never bothers to explain or defend or
provide evidence for any of the claims
he makes here we're supposed to just
believe that nba players witness white
privilege every day don't worry about
the details just go with it
when when a filthy rich nba start
famous beloved celebrated
gets up from his 30 000 couch
and walks over and peers out the window
of his 12-bedroom mansion and sees on
the other side of his iron rod gate a
white family drive by in a used minivan
on their way to buy groceries at the
walmart supercenter
he the nba star
is offended by their incredible
privilege
if only he could have the privilege to
be middle class
forgotten
and despised by millionaires like
himself yes they are the privileged ones
they are victimizing him somehow
don't worry about how
it's racist ask for details
so i won't i won't ask for details
instead i'll just say
you're canceled
you are canceled forever and always
and uh on that note we will leave it
there
for the weekend everyone what i would
recommend is uh just take a break that's
what i'm going to try to do this weekend
take a break from the news
from social media
go hide in a cave somewhere
hide in a cave in there actually i
recommend hiding a cave and never come
out
that's what i'm considering
i'll see if i can still do the podcast
from the cave but we'll find out anyway
have a great weekend talk to you next
week godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens production
manager pablo vadovsky the show is
edited by danny d'amico our audio is
mixed by mike coromina hair makeup is
done by nika geneva and production
assistant mckenna waters the matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 joe biden
stokes racial tensions big tech bans
president trump and another kooky white
lady pretends to be hispanic check it
out on the michael knowles show
[Music]
you